[Music]
candace is with us hey candace how are
you i'm fine
good to have you good to have you where
do you live indianapolis indiana awesome
and all the way here to do a debt-free
scream yep how much do you pay off
234 thousand dollars oh my god
how long did this take 31 months look at
you
i love it and your range of income
during that time
74 000 to two hundred and seventy five
thousand
one oh
what do you do for a living i'm a nurse
practitioner so you went to tribal
nursing huh i did not i stayed um as a
nurse practitioner full-time and then i
worked in the hospital as a nurse
full-time as well
and then i had another part-time mp job
so you're doing 80 90 hours a week 96.
you'll be precise
okay
you're a beast
i want to know i want to know your
schedule what did what did a typical day
because you worked every day during the
week yep so i did
not nine hours on monday tuesday after
monday and tuesday
i worked at my third job on mondays
tuesday i did four hours in my second
job wednesdays i do nine hours i take a
two hour nap then i go to the hospital
for 12 hours
then i take a nap and then i do six
hours
on thursdays
fridays
9 or 10 hours nap 12 hours 12 to 16
hours on saturday how long did you do
this
um 96 hours i did that for the last
probably
nine months and then 80 hours before
that before that
what are you down to now that you're
free um i'm still working a lot but i'm
throwing in vacations with it
you kind of got the rhythm now yeah
okay what kind of debt was the 234
thousand dollars this must be all the uh
all the school debt huh it was a hundred
and fourteen thousand school loans
thirty thousand in one car and sixteen
thousand in another car um 10 000 in
taxes
30 000 in credit cards and
65 000 on a mortgage you paid off your
house
okay no i mean you're single why you
have two cars because i drove a con
convertible
no no in indianapolis it snows and it's
icy yeah
yeah oh my god
yours and you kept them you kept them
and painted them i have both
okay so what happened
what happened months ago that just made
you say 31 months 31 months ago
you went crazy i mean man i guess about
four or five years ago i bought um dave
ramsey's um
the debt-free makeover and i put it to
the side because i was in school and i
couldn't focus and then when i graduated
with my master's degree about a month
after i spent all my credit card money
used all my credit cards and
you realizing that all my money was
going to credit card debt car loans i
picked up the book and i read it in two
days and it was just life transforming
for me from there
um so i started budgeting
i was davish initially and then the end
of 2020
i kind of put the gas on i went gazelle
intense kind of was disappointed in
myself because i did a lot of traveling
trying to pay everything off and i
realized where i could have been
so
2021 january until september when i paid
my school loans off i pretty much did 80
hours and then the last three months to
pay my school loans off i did 96 and
then i kind of kept going and didn't
finish my mortgage off in march wow look
at you
yeah
you are amazing you're a machine this is
so good
was it worth all that
absolutely
absolutely how you feel i feel free
so that's probably the best term that i
can use i feel free
been overwhelmed before weren't you
absolutely overwhelmed discouraged
so
scared scared yeah so tell me this
candles because there's probably people
listening that could be in a very
similar situation of what you were 32
months ago right and they're thinking
but there's no way i can do this there's
no way
i mean this is going to be my life what
would you say to people
that think that way that it's just
impossible they've lost all hope what
would you say
um
i would say just keep pushing um set a
goal stick to it um realize that the
plan can change a million times like
mines did but the goal never changed
yeah my goal was to become debt free and
i'm there for you
just eye on the prize yes i love it wow
so um
where did you learn to work like that
my mother okay yeah so she was the
workers your mom's a wild animal huh
yeah she's a single mom of four she
works oh yeah two jobs always doing
overtime so i've always
had good work work ethic
um so if i want to do if i want
something i go work for it basically
that's it that's it no other way don't
sell that convertible you just i won't
work
i'm gonna just go work extra hours i
love it yeah oh okay so what were people
saying during this journey because
people had to be looking i mean where
worse we do this for a living and we're
still just like wait what you working 96
hours a week uh yeah what was everyone
saying a lot of people were inspired a
lot of people that i work with because
of course i spent a lot of time with
them and my friends of course um i
didn't really share my journey with
everybody until i got down to my last
three months before my school loans off
and my friends were talking about it to
people so they were inspired and like
you should share it so i started posting
and then i did the rings
paying the last fifty thousand of my
school loans so a lot of people were in
tune with that so it was really really
inspiring for me and for them so it was
really really nice
they were definitely inspired a lot of
people were discouraged because they're
like oh i don't make that much well you
don't have 234 000 in debt either and so
you don't work 96 hours a week exactly
so i wow what do you tell people the key
to getting out of debt is just being
consistent
always knowing that you have to
sacrifice
learning the
um aspect of delayed gratification you
know everything we want we usually want
it now
and knowing that sometimes it just takes
time you know even with you know wanting
a new car
you know yep save up the money
wait and then you know you can get your
car or whatever it is that you want just
to delay gratification and getting away
from instant gratification was probably
the biggest key for me
how old are you 31. your mama's got to
be looking at you with tears run down
our faces
i'm really really proud yes yeah i'm
proud of you thank you well done it's
pretty incredible you're an incredible
young woman
and folks you don't have to work like
this your whole life she just did it for
a short period of time yeah to hit a
goal and uh but she knows she can
and you really can't work like that for
five years in a row you can't
your body can't stand it your emotions
can't stand it but for a short period of
time you can turn it on
and really for just under a year you've
been going like a maniac
and uh and now you're free completely
free i figured you went
uh the way the numbers jumped i figured
you went travel nursing that's why i
jumped on that but instead you just took
a zillion hours picked up another
full-time job yeah and there's two
full-time jobs and then a part-time job
yeah and it's all around nursing yeah
and uh always a need isn't there for
nurses really always a shortage yeah
great career path i'm so proud of you
wow you're amazing
absolutely amazing absolutely we got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
that is the next chapter in your story
for sure without a doubt how ordinary
people build extraordinary wealth and
how you can too the daughter of a single
mom raising four kids learned how to
work by watching her mama yep her mama
as you say rachel moore was caught and
taught yep she saw it and uh yeah and i
knew she could and and had the
confidence i mean there's a confidence
that you have that you're like i can do
this i can do
this asked
victor she's not a victim yes that's
right not a victim she's a victor that's
amazing pretty incredible pretty
incredible beautiful stuff it changed
your life yeah i'll be a total money
makeover for you to give away to
somebody and
maybe you can get them started and stir
up a ruckus like you did i have you are
you are something else you are something
else you are amazing all right candace
from indianapolis 234 thousand dollars
paid off in 31 months she did it in two
and a half years 96 hours a week for the
last nine months house and everything
and she's 31 years old two cars single a
hundred percent debt free wow count it
down let's hear a debt free screen
one two three i'm jeffrey